la star la vraie et celle ou celui connu
et aimé de tout ce qui reste à distance
intouchable comme une étoile connu de
tous mais toujours porteur de son
mystère mesdames et messieurs merci
d'accueillir la palme d'honneur à lavaur
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas le regarder tout de suite
parce que sinon je vais pleurer alors
on a souvent dit qu'alain delon parler
lui à la troisième personne
mais aujourd'hui c'est moi qui vais le
faire et comme c'est un homme à silence
je vais tenter de faire court et surtout
tenter de faire bien impose ta chance
serre ton bonheur et va vers ton risque
à te regarder ils s'habitueront est un
peu qui se sont habitués
quand les femmes s'en mêlent alain delon
devient acteur et se retrouve rapidement
en plein soleil tantôt flics dans tout
ça mouraille tantôt guépard il a tout
conquis en vrai homme pressé en 81 9
film i love to pardon excusez moshi
tellement ému il a fait 89 films en 62
ans de carrière un palmarès à faire
pâlir plus d'un jeune débutant mois
comprise dans borsalino françois capella
disait la chance ça n'existe pas je suis
pas d'accord je pense que toi au
contraire tu as eu beaucoup de chance la
chance d'avoir ta gueule
la chance d'avoir ton talent et la
chance d'avoir tourné avec les plus
grands
mais je pense surtout que c'est le
cinéma qui a eu la chance d'avoir la
chance de voir
[Applaudissements]
je pense que le cinéma a beaucoup de
chance de t'avoir parce que tu es un
homme de principe
un homme de conviction entier vrai et
pleins d'audace un battant papa tu as
souvent dit que tu étais très fier de ta
carrière et ya de quoi mais aujourd'hui
c'est moi qui suis fier fier de l'acteur
mais surtout fière de toi et c'est avec
une immense fierté que nous promettons
la palme d'or d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
et hop
donc j'ai pas autant je suis ma vie mais
pardon oui pas seulement de bonheur je
vais vous dire pourquoi je suis heureux
de cette palme d'or d'abord parce que ma
fille et je nettoie oblige il attend
d'accord avec moi mais c'est surtout
parce que je l chose au monde je suis
sur quelque chose au monde je suis fier
vraiment la somme de ma carrière et
c'est alors on l'a offert pour ma
carrière et pour rien d'autre c'est pour
ça que j'ai re est content il satisfait
[Applaudissements]
je veux demander pardon parce que ce
soir pour moi plus qu'une fin de
carrière je pense l'issue d'une fin de
vie
ce soir c'est un peu un hommage posthume
[Musique]
mais de mon vivant
[Rires]
c'est quand j'ai commencé ce métier on
me dit il ya une chose qui est difficile
qui n'est pas difficile c'est de faire
métier qui veut faire ci est très
difficile c'est de durer et j'ai durée
j'ai joué 62 ans
maintenant je sais que ce qui est
difficile c'est de partir lorsque je
vais partir mais je ne partirai pas je
ne partirai pas sans vous le dirai sans
vous remercier
lorsque j'ai fait bon musique ma vie je
les fais du mieux que je pouvais elle ce
soir cette projection a bouleversé maroc
ont traité de tas de choses mais j'ai
fait un métier que j'ai choisi dirigé
par les plus grands les meilleurs et
paraît-il paraît-il je suis élue star
mais si je suis une star et c'est pour
ça que je veux vous remercier
c'est au public je dois y aperçoit d'eau
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas les films sont les stars c'est
par le metteur en scène c'est pas ce qui
se passe ça n'est que le public au cours
des années des mois de nombreuses années
qui font les stars il ya beaucoup de
public et il ya peu de stars j'en fais
partie grâce à vous je vous remercie de
tout mon coeur en filmant
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis merci et au revoir
j'espère j'espère que je vais pas trop
déçu mais dame et j'ai jamais pleurer
comme ça dure les femmes
[Applaudissements]
ça m'emmerde parce que je vais encore
blu ray
comme partir très simplement vous dire
que que je pense à mireille un rubis
[Applaudissements]